in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Aaron
and Emily are with us hey guys how are
you hey Dave how's it going welcome
welcome where you guys from
we're from lisbon falls mean i love it
Lisbon Falls Maine now how far north of
Portland is that or South about thirty
minutes north of Portland oh okay
we brought you some nice cool weather
thank you we appreciate you dropping it
off did you drop us off any fresh
lobster though oh well there's always
that well welcome how much debt of you
guys paid off
we paid off sixty thousand in about a
year and three months I love it very
cool very cool
making what kind of money during that
time just north of a hundred all right
very good
love it great great what kind of debt we
had about seventy five hundred in
student loans and the rest was stupid
car loan debt that's a car yes we had
about a year before we had bought a
brand-new truck for him and about six
months before that we've leased a car
for me there you go I'm so all kinds of
stupidity so like goodness gracious so
you're talking like fifty thousand
dollars in cars yep
and and your income is just north of a
hundred Wow yeah you had a lot in cars
so the cars were killing you what
happened tell me the story what got you
started on this so the credit union that
I work for did a promotion where we gave
your book away the Total Money Makeover
for all of our new accounts and so I
read the book at that time and was kind
of blown away with the concept of paying
off debt and I brought it home to him
yeah and then I said well that's like a
scam it's no big deal it's not gonna
work so but then she brought home the
videos from one of our co-workers and we
watched the first video and I'm like oh
we could probably do that we could
participate in the scam then I started
listening to the podcast and then I came
home I'm like we're not supposed to
lease a car why do we lease a car we not
so spy new truck why did I buy a new
truck because nobody told you not to
right that's exactly why so did you sell
them or did you pay them off we ended up
just pushing through and paying them off
Wow
he's self-employed and so the truck was
for his business which it still is but
and now it's paid for that's the first
thing you said I'll do this plan but I'm
not selling my truck okay so he got to
keep that but you did it in 15 months
right yeah which is a little bit in
savings that's actually our rule is that
if you can be debt-free house and I mean
everything but the house and you want to
keep the cars you can do it within two
years then and as long as the cars don't
equal more than half your annual income
which in value which these two don't in
value they did in debt but they don't in
value right so you're there so good job
very cool so you kept the fleeced car
paid it off yes yeah everybody not to do
that ever
yeah ever again very cool house you feel
it's free yeah freeing because you had
what $1,000 in car payments yep yes yeah
definitely it was awful well and in the
budget too I mean just doing a budget
was incredible we found so much money
yeah when we sat down and gave our money
a purpose so did you have that moment
like Sharon and I did Sharon and I were
doing that and we were like where has it
all been going yes right I could we
could have done so much he came to me
that and I kept saying participate help
me and yeah so now we're team Hamilton
which is really exciting that's a good
thing when you're married yeah yeah good
good so Aaron and Emily very fun so
people make fun of you while you're
doing this
sometimes when we'd say we have to
budget for and they'd be like what are
you talking about yeah we're doing that
next week and we're like no we had a
budget for it so we can't do it till
next month I think people are more
annoyed with us because we just kept
talking about it and they really shut up
already
we got through it now they're asking us
questions you know you're walking around
going I got my debt free stickers no
yeah like I voted today you got that
sticker right yeah yeah that's cool we
ought to get some stickers like that cat
you know we could do that when you come
in I did my debt free scream hearing a
lot more of the sticker around town all
day that's something else we could spend
money on around here but yeah okay good
very cool you guys that's neat
congratulations thank you so what do you
tell people the secret to getting out of
debt is probably the budget the budgets
the number one just making sure
everything's where you want it to go so
once you had a plan it wasn't hard to
stick to it
right
well yeah until I wanted to get my
pedicures done there ah yeah okay he had
to give up his TV which was very sad oh
yeah the DirecTV that was a big hit oh
well now you can get it back they never
hesitate to sell it to you why your dad
I'll trade you a pedicure for my direct
right so very cool so what was the
biggest budget fight you had my car yeah
we get forth on whether to keep it or
pay it off or trade down and I said well
the formula he gives on the podcast says
we can keep it and she's like oh I want
to get out I want to get out and then
she went test drove something lesser
than what she had and she's like I think
I want to keep my car all that
philosophy went down the down the test
drive but you said earlier you know once
you pay it off you kind of hate it and
now I kind of paint my car because I'm
thinking it's way too much yeah I don't
think it is I think if it was too much I
would tell you you're I mean you're
under the mark the thing is you just it
was too much the way you did it and
there's still got that I still got that
it doesn't shine like it should you know
right it will again well again because
otherwise you get to drive one those
things your test drove you drove like no
one else you can drive like no one else
so congratulations you guys how does it
feel to not have any payments but your
house just amazing just like we could do
anything yeah we can provide for our son
we have a two-year-old at home and
mm-hmm
we can change his future and and we
could come to Nashville to meet you
right Wow there you go well thanks guys
we're honored to have you here very fun
Aaron and Emily from Maine I love it
$60,000 paid off in 15 months making
over a hundred that's their cars and
everything and they kept them plowed
through did the hard work
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two one
and the crowd goes wild
I love it I love it I love it way to go
you guys very proud of you